so what do tell you what is Wednesday I
hope you were going to be here but we
met at the accelerator coaching
mentoring program that's right so thank
you though thank you in a gold
interested what yeah yeah it's been
twelve months now killing it now so
thank you
yeah you're welcome great working with
you so just give me a very quick fast
nutshell and we're going to pack what
you're doing the wrong angle that yes so
I started very little money maybe about
1,500 pounds and now my essays doing so
well we've got about three thousand five
hundred a month coming in on averaging
off some months a little bit more
someone's a little bit less on average
yeah that's awesome
so what I want to talk about in this
interview because there's there's been a
lot of people that be saying to me and
Sammy what you've said you look to fail
because you've talked people that have
young red to serviced accommodation
elves all of these forty of students and
now making lots of money of registers
accommodation but now with Corona they
were going to now be on the streets you
left your job and we only full-time the
a property due rent serviced
accommodation so I want to unpack that
but but but but I also want to just
figure out what you've done how you've
got there talk to me now they're a
little about Chrome because it's very
very topical topical it's affecting
everybody things are all closed down
yeah but basically lockdown how is that
affecting your rent service
accommodation business so Chrome a cron
is funny because it's it's a terrible
thing you know people have died and so
it's so sad for for for service
accommodation I believe you know some
crazies here that's a good thing
okay okay half the market is dropping
out all my properties are full with a
minute okay people people are losing
money and service combination in a
minute because they're not adapting
they're not they're still going for
holiday let's yeah okay I'm looking for
people the holiday that's you know come
in you come into 2 nights three nights
for is I'm looking for people I've got
to get through this month because it's
gonna it's gonna boom yeah once this is
over because half the markets gone so
you if you can get through this next two
three months you're gonna you're gonna
be killing it
so what I've done I have I think the
best thing in business you can have
is ever like a piece of paper okay yeah
sat down one day for who is my target he
was my type audience because no one's
gone on holiday at a minute yeah it's
your body's language service
accommodation which is 50% of serviced
accommodation and no one's working away
from home and I mean it's all the work
injured um so that's that's you full-si
business game so who who can i who can I
send my market not to who can I get to
stay in my accommodation
so I'm not losing money so I'm still
making money so I sat down I had a thing
few hours bug newspaper and number one
on my list are expats expats are
flocking home with a minute you know
three four my properties are full with
people coming back from Australia yeah
they're coming back to see the parents
they're scared for the parents yeah they
need some want to stay they don't want
to put they don't want to go on an ASD
contract because they got to put down
your big deposit you know you're gonna
be in for six months I don't know if
it's gonna be here for six weeks eight
weeks three months they don't know how
long I'm gonna be playing so it's not
even well well everyone I don't know if
they're still going on well yeah they
are since I got a few friends are in
South American there call me back next
week but um but yeah they've come back
they're all from Australia for me I know
you say these people want to be with
their family but you have me with a file
on his home so all these people even if
they're not able to come right now maybe
they are maybe they're not there's a lot
of people that have cut their flocking
back and going now there's houses that
are overcrowded yep and you're saying
hey actually of course I've got some
self-isolation you've nothing and those
types of people there's more people in
the UK have that make sense okay what
else
so as well you know NHS is under much
pressure one of my next off to hospital
steps away from the hospital
you know yeah there's people going in
and it's just stuff that I work in that
needs to be next the hospital they're
gonna be working twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen hour shifts yeah they
don't want to have an element hour yeah
they so you know advertised SAT put some
of the are marking bars in hospitals and
things like
you can just sucked on things another
one of my strategies I did as well is
everyone even though it no one's about
everyone starts to go to the supermarket
every person's got a soup right you've
been to the supermarket if family's
going to the supermarket you need to go
get food there's mark important
supermarkets yeah ok slap a supper thing
on short term rental one month two
months three month
yeah all these people experts are coming
back they need to go get food I'm going
to else to go I've seen this word of my
family month you know they're all
telling them yeah that's why I've got
one of my my beads from I knew a big
bookie recently yeah yeah well every
every one of them's a booking I'm just
waiting for my last one to fill up and
literally have just got an inquiry you
know when I was on my for ten minutes
ago that yeah I wasn't inquiry for us
Daniel always sorry it's crazy that you
get inquiries now because it is what was
that now it's a very strange time yeah
I'm to say that the SA markets not going
to be impacted would be ridiculous it
clearly has been impacted but what
you're saying is you got to adapt you've
got to adapt business yes sir if you
keep doing the same thing in this in
this time talk to me about everybody
else that's quitting because I know
there's a lot of people that are doing
service compilation that on haven't got
the you know the experience is more than
training than you've got and then just
kind of a bigger batch got a couple
properties and how they're they're
freaking out and they're a lot of people
are walking away from their service they
then they're utilizing their break
clauses they're walking away what do you
think that's going to do because you
said there's not duty in there
well there's opportunity and everything
isn't that I think when people are
panicking that's the time where the
opportunity is calm so everyone's
leaving the market because I think
they're only the stock staying with
holiday lets and they're not getting
booked so they're thinking great I need
to I need to get rid of my serviced
accommodation so I've seen so many deals
just not even people charging for
dealers you know I need to get rid of it
it's need to get it gone so I mean if
you if you want to grow your serviced
accommodation now is your time to be
drawing I think
yeah you get cheap deals there's so many
on the market you can take the cream of
the crop yeah exactly
yeah and you can find people that I've
got service accommodation use
development anymore yeah so many of
since so many on Facebook you know I'm
gonna I think I'm gonna take a few more
and hopefully yeah having fun
took a five at the moment and you'll
make it how much profit huge so about
three and a half thousand partners so
our first property what about a hundred
pound if and how long have you had them
for where did you first one so my first
one was roughly about ten months ago
yeah another months ago I got my first
deal I really struggled in my first deal
I didn't know I didn't really know what
I was doing I had so many parties in
that I had prostitutes in there as well
it I think was with the joint venture
cause I'm with a JV ventured JV partner
so I mean I'm so I'm so grateful for him
coming in as well so like I'd like to
say thank you through her shell so I
appreciate that mom yeah and I was about
to pack in yeah and I mean shells in a
jar and he was like what what are our
options I want to charge because Chaz is
invested money with me here yeah and I
want him to scare some money back so I
said to him shells look I'll I'll buy
you out when and I'll outside wall while
doing you know maybe I can sell this
deal for 3 3 K later on downline but
somewhat changed that that month and I
started realizing it was a business I'm
gonna have obstacles I need to overcome
any to grow and learn
yeah and it just it just changed and I
grew I grew I grew a little bit and I
adopted my business and and it snowball
sense so that's amazing and I look
forward to unpacking all the details of
that and I think that right now as well
there's so many people handing back
their units people are freaking out and
the smart people are just saying yeah as
Warren Buffett says when people are
scared that is when you should be greedy
and was I don't want to stand here and
say oh let's all be greedy right now no
it's very sad people are suffering
therefore so so you know we need to be
saved we need to be mindful but at the
same time we need to we need to survive
through this
this period we can't just go into pad
mode let's talk about your German
so when how did you first hear about me
how did you first come to the crash
course my journey starts a while back go
on to senior you'll laugh at this so I
always knew I wanted to be in property
because when I left school I just think
want to work yeah that was my goal I
didn't want to have a job I didn't want
to be slave in my life away because I
just want to enjoy life I think my
life's there to be enjoyed
so I thought well I'll buy a house and I
can live off the rental income so
looking at houses in whole you know
whether like 40 50 thousand pound and a
fall hey I've got ten grand a Aachen
when I saw Mike I had 10 grand I was
like I can't I can buy a house I was
paid down as much as I can and then I'll
be making 400 parliament friend now it's
like on Japan a week and I'm not going
to work and I was its chips or that was
my plan just to pay off as fast as I
could and then I read a venture book and
I read Simon's which his book is it yeah
no matter status I realized you need to
educate yourself and I thought my god
does the worst plan I've ever had in my
life but you didn't buy it you were
gonna didn't buy it now it's going to
buy yeah I was like there was a worst
plan ever had in my life so I realized I
need to educate myself yeah so looked
around you know and obviously you're
born on YouTube with property so I come
across you and I went to the clash boss
I don't so much
my father says kept thinking my god so
glad I didn't buy the house sound-up see
Academy didn't know where I'll going
with the money is my money I use my
money to sign up to the cupboard see you
Sora you sold your car yeah so my always
I sold my baby my Scirocco you sure rock
out and how did you even afford your
Scirocco because when we met you 21 yeah
yeah so I was working as working
full-time in sales yeah
slaving away working
till nine and I was killing myself I
hated it I had no life five and a half
days a week but it was six full days
yeah just just up my Sunday's and which
was recovery day which was recovery day
which wasn't fun and my philosophy is
just wanna enjoy life okay so you're
sick of working sick away at all
I'm gonna sell my car and I'm gonna use
my car to to become financially free
yeah your plan was to buy a house
yes Olli you know this is what a house
to buy I came across the crash course
Karen on to the crash course to put it
still in my house I'm gonna invest in
myself so you have 10 grand and you put
all of that into your education what
every penny oh yeah so what happened you
on the Academy because I know you
weren't particularly happy you
comfortable Oh God so join the Academy
adhara I joined the Academy and we we
other wanted to once one you know it's
all sit around the table there's six or
seven of us
and we was with with one of the coaches
yeah it was like that's that's about
your journey but first of all we we need
to understand way right now so remember
on the table and this this couple here
was like it he asked how much do you
guys got to invest the mob and they said
we've got four hundred thousand pounds
to invest and I'm gonna keep this show
yeah I know it's the next one we've got
we've got 250,000 pounds invest no
documents me please don't consider and
the next one was like 150 and I think
the lowest was something like 80,000
pound they've got to invest and he comes
to me and I was like
1,500 even have that to buskers and
anyone's at best because if I spend are
I'm not getting I'm getting money
Sequoia point petrol
yeah so you literally 1500 pounds j9
1500 passed my name and so so aren't
away did did my courses and then I got
my first friend deal through I was
saying the star don't venture partner
but here's the thing you found poor in
the room oh yeah where you felt like a
kid
oh yeah I felt like a kid I felt out of
my depth yeah I felt like it because but
the thing is you happen to be sat on the
table with people that wealth because a
lot of people on the Academy I mean
you're stay young that much money you
happen to just be sad that I grew people
that were really wealthy but I love the
fact that you flip the card and use that
to advantage because Shaz he was was he
on the table yeah she has on table
so your first to a venture partner was
with one of these Academy members that
had my name so so tell me how that how
that happens so the deep with me if you
get a great deal someone's gonna invest
movie I think you know I forgot until
mrs. a this is a fantastic essay deal
yes made me manager partner Bridgnorth
so let's call mr. promise for you so I
mean I just said look this is my deal I
need the money
let's do it yeah and you know he funded
it under how much did he have to put him
oh I think it was about three thousand
pounds
yeah is around about that but he put
three grand in but you speaking to me
earlier but it's really interesting
because you said that that deal was
actually it was actually rubbish Talia I
was bad at the start because I didn't
know I was doing I was an experienced
how the issues of process you know
issues for parties and it was causing me
some of stress and first few points you
don't make much money
cause you know he terrier views you need
to understand the market as well so it
was just panic yeah and it was stress
and I was I've been through I've been on
a rollercoaster of emotions for this for
these last 12 months and I was close to
backing him you have so close and us but
we're gonna get there in a minute
because when we met at the a CMP I want
to slap you yeah yeah but but when you
did that deal with showers you told me
that the deal was terrible yeah and you
felt bad yeah and you ended up in chess
back yeah I needed to get shallots money
that was my first priority
yeah I didn't want chefs lose up because
if I went to it if we went into a
partnership or anything you've gotta be
my number one concern yeah I need you to
get who I promised you okay yes if I'm
gonna if I say you're gonna get this I
need you to get lost
I need that else like my reputation is
gonna be top okay so I got to not go to
the comments money and we're close or
close to I was costing him enough Oh
someone changed to me saying that pushes
put three penguins deal and then you
think - as I was prostitutes it's
rubbish it's horrible yeah well Howard
had anemia well Chad's lives in
Birmingham so he's a long way from me
and he didn't want anything he does want
hands-off experience yeah so I had to I
had to manage it but he was cool you
know he's a good guy but it was making a
bigger profit still yeah I was making
profit how much I was probably spending
like 300 homage for the first few months
you know just how I was a lot possible
how did you pay back so we might like
300 I'd had a small bit as well going so
just literally you put it all aside yeah
paid off
yeah but then my original with her 1500
as well so yeah yeah so I was like so
now you're absolutely done public so
this is one saying you know I've got if
I'm if I'm promising an investor some
phenomena I've got it I'll make it work
yeah and then when you paid Shaz off
what happened I was in it myself
I was costing given up but somewhat
changed I saw a groom and I started
learning it a bit more each day I'd
learn about prostitutes what can I do to
minimize that yeah I want to taking one
that bookings anymore our skin so I was
taking security deposits now and York
where my most Mercedes are you'd never
expect that you'd never expect that York
you see it somewhere like Manchester
senator but I mean there's somewhere but
York it's I couldn't believe it I think
we couldn't believe it there's only
three prostitutes in the whole New York
and they're all in your all in my so we
had the a CMP and you were a bit down
our stock and the AC impedes the
accelerate coach mentoring program and
it's quite an interesting program
because if there's no content all I'm
just like house it won't do it
and the crazy thing is in that whole
room remember how many people there was
you could put it back me up but from the
whole rhythms any one person that wasn't
making any money
yeah I think you're right every single
person was making money property they
weren't killing yeah never so making
they're making some money not us was
about everybody need to do was win some
repeat wasn't yeah and you said to me
after like you know this sucks your
whole body language was was was like
terrible and and I said to you what's
going on and you told me and you are
making nine hundred quid a month only
and it's it's been a nightmare subdued
and we did a bit training and what
happened yeah so who worked on sales
that's where that's why we're struggling
because you were struggling to get more
rent events yeah yeah so I come for
themselves back running my job and I
thought God create a sales terrible yeah
actually was terrible and actually yeah
it was embarrassing to think I was good
at sales so common I've come to the I've
come to the viewings
smashing laws of us okay the Lord's
about and I be of these blowing all
pitch in
you know this Ormond give you this this
and they're like okay I'll let you know
let's say I'll just take that for the
answer I'll just take a light not so so
we do work on sales about asking
questions things things like that you
know you different yeah Rob we dissing
wrong way as well and then I think maybe
three weeks later got my second deal and
then what was a reading at a time forgot
what it was but come on effect yeah it
was a compound effect keep working
yeah don't stop because people stop to
celebrate yeah so I've got the deal
gotta stop the celebrate I won't be
going on my viewings book I kept on
going on my viewings you know I've got
my deal and then I think within like
three days later that was my third deal
yeah I couldn't believe I've got two two
deals in one week and I couldn't get I
couldn't get with over the past six
months I know it's all in one week um
and and it's no waltz so what changed
then what changed what were you saying
differently that you won't do before
understand sales a lot better yeah I'd
like to selves get a lot of sales
handling rejections and objections yeah
I've wrote a book as well actually yeah
yeah yeah small book and I've been given
out to people oh man you've done bit of
a dark horse here I need to see this
book Sonia short books about 15 16 pages
just on how to handle objections in yeah
in rent to rent sector yeah brilliant
so I listed every objection I got about
stalls and objection so you need to
understand the difference between a
stall and a rejection yeah okay so you
need to get to the objection okay and
then you can overturn yeah and so I've
got I've got the Lords of listed handle
it
things have all bullet-point you don't
want to say we're different things and
also if any of the viewers who just hit
on the lead magnet
yeah yeah yes sir honestly it's a great
book and the last 10 viewings I've been
on I've closed 9 deals Fox has a book I
can take them all on because some of
these issues and yeah so what does it
mean the head beliefs think once that
miss so every apartment block they come
with a like a TNCs basically you're not
allowed to hang your towels on the edge
of your rail just absolutely anything
like that and someone will say you know
how to use but use a business inside the
premises yeah so if you were uneducated
like a lot of people honest in this game
yeah they're taking on their properties
to spend in three four thousand pound
uplifting and then in six seven weeks
they get in a call hey you can't do this
anymore you know that's a big expense
that's a very big that's actually I
didn't meet a landlord that's a weird
potential si I went round to viewed the
place places gorgeous
he liked the idea of everything we doing
but definitely didn't allow it and he
simply bought that property to do
serviced accommodation all the property
okay so I think cuz you're quite an
expensive to place the body and the
center he put with it with its deposit
and everything use in like 50 60 K yeah
for his freezer plan not to work so you
know definitely be educated and that's
the that's the importance of having
their skills and education but then also
being able to speak to people to sell
that I mean that scale that was that was
the moment via yeah that changed for me
I now I mean you full time I promise oh
yeah full time tell me tell me the story
of where you quit your job so quit my
job maybe or twelve months ago now I see
we go really oh yeah yeah yeah you just
do you have you got you even got a
single deal
sorry you quit your job to do what now
this new wellness didn't want to work I
knew I had to make it work and I believe
if you're not under pressure
yeah you're not gonna so what is it join
the Academy you spent your last penny
that you got from selling your car
during the entire domain yeah you had no
job no job you in a very vulnerable
situation so I read a read Rich Dad Poor
Dad yeah and that obviously that's a
mindset as a game changer yeah I went to
work the next day I'll follow him one
day and I just stood at the front doors
these two big glass doors and I was like
me anymore
this isn't me so I turned around and
they were shot wouldn't be like come on
get working I was like no more I'm done
so it's when I quit I'm leaving and I
walked straight out the door
I felt so great I'm not smoke on the way
home as drivers like my girlfriend was
ill at the time Beth and she was she was
in bed at home and a fault that's gone
all day today I just got so went on
pack your bags Beth we're off to the
airport within an hour of Lee quit my
job
we're on way to Manchester Airport and
we went to Tenerife through a week and
the same day I was stopped I was sat on
my er I saw the Sun the beach and I was
looking across the Mars thinking god
I've made the right decision here yeah
definitely but give me you give me
clarity as well you know give me a
confidence to do what wanted and give me
time to think about where I want to go
with business as well yeah what was it
like when you were just at the beach in
Tenerife thank you this morning I was at
work actually one on the beach other
I've rented a surfboard and I saw some
on the scientist even better a surfboard
on doesn't know ice this coffin was an
average day at live view I realize when
I become finite you for finance you free
it's not it's not
it's not it's not any different -
because you've been making the same
amount of money yes when you at work but
everyone else does it work yeah it's a
really sat by itself so it's quiet it's
lonely we can be lonely but now I know
that I have to get rich yeah so uh so my
girlfriend can leave her job my mom can
leave a job yeah you know so people
around me can enjoy life rather than
just me yeah that's that's that's my
goal for this next a unique scholars to
get to a point where your family and you
go for my family are also financially
free
yeah so that's happened you want to stop
and go well I need to start building
wealth so I mean we've been looking at
I've been looking at some PR our deals
yeah in Barnsley we were looking just
this more just looking this morning work
we have some cracking deals yeah and you
know I'm just looking I'm looking for
that next next once yeah yes because now
you've got you've got Network you know
experience you got time at a time a lot
of times I've got confidence how much
more confident now than six twelve
minutes ago though I can really do than
that I know any confidence not a follow
us quite a confident person until I
started coming to events and pin
meetings and things like that yeah
talking like this and you know why did
you go what did you feel like I felt
like a kid yeah so the kid didn't always
do it but but now I'm novice on that I'm
one of the last people that yeah I'll be
standing up Selvam you know yeah yeah
you change massively you don't just your
circumstances are being financially free
but also your confidence your energy is
completely different in a very very
positive way and the thing as well
financially free to be really flexed
when I became financially for elves
early 20s and did we sit there on my
dear one missin appliance you free I'm
not rich
yeah you're not rich there's not a
difference you've just got time yes I'm
driving the same conic car in a normal
house the difference is to sustain my
lifestyle I don't have to go to work
yeah
that's the only yeah that's where I
month at the minute yeah so you've got
some re-focus who finds opportunities
unless some great opportunities
yeah
opportunities and bonds and I'll be
second to this morning if in order for
you to scale you should be going back to
some of the Academy members and say
thank you for supporting in serviced
accommodation look I've become very
successful in this I'm financially free
now on the same wood burner my portfolio
and in do some joint ventures and raise
some finance but yeah you saw some
butter yeah and I'm gonna harder to put
your own if you've got a website
although I thought web so I'm gonna put
that as a description in this link if
they aren't my earth if we I can have my
facebook if anyone wants that yeah yeah
oh just fine call yeah so anyone honored
with the details in this be life and
then was talk to you about whether it's
the blog whether it's doing business
with you you know I can vouch for you
you're a top guy and I've really enjoyed
working with you over the last year what
is it people like the experience on the
Panama I've lost a Academy I think the
best thing about the Academy is the
people you meet yeah like I I would have
been able to grow if I didn't have the
network around me yeah so that's amazing
the knowledge is amazing I wouldn't be
where I am if I weren't for the Academy
absolutely there's no way yeah I've been
asleep and I'm five still suck so six
days a week six days five and a half
days six days oh yeah what I saw I'm
grateful I'm so grateful my and set up
your call is probably the best that you
did some of my baby yeah I want to buy
the same color
yeah that actual car not not the same
actual car someone hopefully I'm gonna
track and drag it out
do it do it drunk because that's the
thing is it's like short sort of
sacrifice for the long-term
yeah and to take sometimes and in the
same well I mean people that say about
10 grand and and they want to buy a
house and I'll say don't buy a house put
it in your education put it in yourself
because if you bought a house you're
gonna make sure you quit a month yes
what we do and then we can you said
another tank round and keep doing that
if you put it in yourself it's its toes
it's once that may be back you might
feel like but then it's going to be a
hundred
forward because beautiful house you'd be
still do your job you just pretend we
don't look they're off
yeah it's not an ism no but it's now
you're three and a half thousand Panama
barrel and Counting what would you
advise me to someone watching this it's
like where you were twelve months ago
educate yourself reading books you know
audibles amazing yeah all it was so good
you know I owe a lot of success to
audible as well read books case all for
networking join an academy just learn
and I don't care it's more analysis try
I know you don't I know you don't you
know so just get trained gets trained
yeah what's it been like working man
great love them you know when we did our
once one together on that work you send
them two days that's that's what changed
for me yeah that's what changed and then
it's snow Watson so I'm very grateful
for that
yeah the ACM piece awesome consider a
coach a mentor me two days lots of
people but holiday tree does go around
the whole well not many when we were
there I think no no it's not but every
body there was more person yeah was
making money you property and I think
that's the thing when you're in a room
full of people and some of them are
disappointed soon what I'm only making
me grant a month but still around a
month in recurring property coming after
three six months of being on the Academy
ignite in my book is not a failure you
know it's not a failure and it's easy to
suppose beat yourself up it's not being
faster if you know it's not been fast Oh
what I mean brings well here bomb here
anything else where it's it you you've
been going that yeah so you begin a year
and you're making three and a half
thousand a month that is not bad when
you look at the big picture just because
some people do in three months ah you
did really really well
thanks my so so what's the main focus
then so you can do this BRR in Barnsley
yes that's the next step early the
partners yeah
yeah maybe you know John mentioned
partner yeah so something that's got
cash yeah no time yep some full time
yeah experience and I've got some great
deals as well yeah we've seen these
deals you know I'm saying that other
things okay others he's looking at kind
of think that you know I'm definitely
expecting to see you yeah be able to you
know retire you mom and I think that's
going to happen and when we met you were
21 you naturally three yeah it's 23 not
awesome
okay top three so we're gonna spot now
top three best notice that you've got to
end this interview on work work every
day if even if it's just making one
phone call yeah work every single day
don't focus on again again yeses from
people focus on hitting rejections yeah
so for instance it's so many rejections
before any day yes more CEO rejection as
or what doesn't work yeah just imagine
if you had to get a hundred rejection
before you get yes yeah okay
so just your rejections all time yeah
that's key and be an education you know
keep you in any books because that's
what you're getting knowledge from me my
three things as fantastic and this
corona stuff moving it we're gonna push
through it all again through it no
problem yeah no problem change your
strategy a little bit change it out yeah
get through this and it's gonna be a
after because everyone else given up
everyone's given up half the markets
gone already half the market New Yorkers
dropped out yeah believe it I think into
thing amongst I'm gonna sit over it's
gonna it's gonna be even less it's just
gonna go yeah well I think so I need to
then even in people people other
comments - a-are you being talked to
this there is this girl lost for six
months but I've lost fun I'd rather be
optimistic Tyler yes because because
being
moping around being negative and
panicking is not going to get anyone
anywhere
to change adapt because they're there
for you for your own peace of mind and
well-being as well
and I definitely think that you're gonna
get better results when you think like
that and I mean it's great to see your
business not get affected too much yet
go to synaptic and local to see
[Music]